>> THIS IS A
>> THIS IS A TEST.
TESTING.
>> THOSE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
DEFEATED AND YOU ARE MOVING FROM
A PROPOSAL FOR UNLIMITED TAXING
POWER.  CONSTITUTION AUTHORIZES
CONGRESS TO CREATE A NAVY AND
CALL INTO FEDERAL SERVICE
WITHOUT RESTRICTION.  NOW, YOU
NEED TO COMPARE WITH THE
ARTICLES AND UNDER THE ARTICLES,
CONGRESS CAN
REQUISITION.  NOW, YOU HAVE
CONGRESS THAT CAN RAISE AN ARMY,
NOT ONLY DURING WARTIME, BUT
DURING PEACETIME AND NO LIMITS
TO DURATION AND IF THEY HAVE TO
GET A SUPER MAJORITY COMMITMENT
AND THAT'S A SHIFT OF POWER TO
THE NATIONAL GOVERNMENT AND AT
THE TIME, THEY FELT THAT
STANDING ARMIES WERE VERY
DANGEROUS TO THE ENEMY AND THEY
THOUGHT THAT CONGRESS WOULD
PRESENT DISPERSE.  AND THE
LIMITED POWER.  AND FOURTH,
CONGRESS HAS IMPLIED POWERS
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION AND
ARTICLES OF CONFEDERATION AND
EXPRESSLY PROVIDES THAT CONGRESS
MAY ONLY EXERCISE THOSE POWERS
THAT ARE EXPRESSLY DELEGATED AND
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION, THE
CONSTITUTION CLEARLY AUTHORIZES
IMPLIED POWERS AND LISTED IN
ARTICLE ONE, SECTION EIGHT AND
CONGRESS ALSO HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO PASS LAWS THAT ARE NECESSARY
AND PROPER TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE OTHER POWERS OF THE
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S EXPLICIT
OF THE CONGRESS IMPLIED POWERS.
THAT WAS AN INTENSELY
PROPOSITION IN THE RATIFYING
PROCESS AND FINALLY, THE
CONSTITUTION IMPLIES THE
MECHANISM FOR A ENFORCEMENT OF
FEDERAL CONFEDERACY AND THE
TREATIES WITHIN THE
CONFEDERATION
CONGRESS, BUT THE CONFEDERATION
CONGRESS HAD NO WE WAY OF
IMPLEMENTING.  GIVING THE
NATIONAL GOVERNMENT THE
AUTHORITY ANY POWER TO VETO ANY
STATE LAW IT FELT LIKE VETOING
AND INSTEAD, THEY CAME UP WITH
A 3-PART PROVISION FOR
ESTABLISHING FEDERAL SUPREMACY
AND IT IS THE FEDERAL SUPREMECY
CAUSE IN ARTICLE SIX OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND IT IS SUPREME
OVER STATE LAW TO THE CONTRARY.
SECOND, THE CONSTITUTION CREATES
A FEDERAL COURT SYSTEM AND
THERE WERE NONE UNDER THE
ARTICLE.
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
AND CONGRESS IS AUTHORIZED, BUT
NOT REQUIRED TO CREATE THE
FEDERAL SUPREME COURT AND YOU
HAVE THE FEDERAL
JUDICIALS THAT WILL ENFORCE THE
FEDERAL SUPREMACY AND NO STATE
SHALL MAKE ANYTHING FOR GOLD OR
SILVER LEGAL TENDER AND STATES
SHALL NOT PROVIDE THE OBLIGATION
OF CONTRACT AND THAT'S
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED TO THE
PAPER MONEY LAWS AND THE DEBTOR
RELIEF LAWS AND THE MAJORITY OF
THE STATES HAVE BEEN PASSING IN
THE
MID 17 '80S AND OTHER THAN THE
GREAT DEPRESSION AND THE
MAJORITY OF THE STATES THAT
ENACTED THE RELIEF LEGISLATION
AND IT IS AN
OFFICIAL FORM AND THE DEBTORS
AND THEY WANTED TO SUPPRESS THAT
THROUGH THE CONSTITUTION.  IT
IS IMPORTANT AND WORTH TAKING
NOTE OF THE FACT THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE STATES HAD
PASSED THESE LAWS IN THE MID
1780'S AND HOW REPRESENTATIVE
THE OPINION WAS IN THE COUNTRY.
NOSE ARE THE NATIONALIST
PROVISIONS AND LET ME TURN TO
THE ANTI-POP PEW LIST PROVISIONS
AND ARTICLE
TEN IS AN
ANTI-POP PEW
LIST  LIST LEGISLATION.  THIS
IS RELATIVE TO THE ARTICLES AND
STATE CONSTITUTION AND UNDER THE
ARTICLES THE STATE
REPRESENTATIVES SPEND ONE YEAR
IN OFFICE AND UNDER THE STATE
CONSTITUTION AND THE LOWER HOUSE
HAD AN
HAD AN YULE TERMS IN OFFICE AND
THE MAJORITY OF STATES HAD
GOVERNORS WHO SERVED ANNUAL
TERMS IN OFFICE AND SOME STATE
SENATES.  AS YOU KNOW, UNDER THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION, THE
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVES
SERVED TWO YEARS, THE PRESIDENT
SERVED FOUR YEARS.  MOST OF THE
DELEGATES WANTED TO GO FURTHER
IN EXTENDING THE TERM IN OFFICE.
FOUR STATE DELEGATIONS VOTED AT
ONE POINT FOR LIFETIME TENURE
FOR THE PRESIDENT.  THAT'S A
SCARY THOUGHT FOR YOU, DONALD
TRUMP AS A LIFETIME PRESIDENT.
HAMILTON WANTED SENATORS AND
PRESIDENTS TO BE LIFETIME
TENURE.  HE FELT THAT WAS THE
ONLY WAY THAT YOU COULD
ADEQUATELY PROTECT THE PROPERTY
RIGHTS AND THEY MADE A
RADIFICATION AND THAT'S WHY THEY
REDUCED THE TERM TO 2, 4, AND 6
YEARS.  AS YOU KNOW THE
SENATORS WERE ELECTED FOR THE
STATE LEGISLATURES AND THAT
REMAINED THE CASE
UNTIL 1913.  THE PRESIDENT WERE
AND STILL ARE CHOSEN BY THE
METHODS THAT ARE CHOSEN BY THE
STATE LEGISLATURES.  TODAY, WE
ASSUME THAT WAS GENERAL
ELECTIONS.  IT DIDN'T MATTER.
NOBODY WAS VOTING FOR PRESIDENT
AND THEY IN
THELY -- INDEPENDENTLY
DELIBERATED AND CHOSE THE
PRESIDENT.  THE REASON FOR THAT,
THEY DISTRUSTED THE PEOPLE TO
CHOSE THE NATION'S DELEGATE.
QUOTING "IT WOULD IMPROPER TO
DEFER THAT CHOICE TO THE PEOPLE
AS IT WOULD BE TO DEFER A TRIAL
OF COLORS TO A BLIND MAN".
THINK ABOUT THAT.  THE PEOPLE
CAN'T POSSIBLY TRUSTED TO CHOOSE
THEIR REPRESENTATIVE.  IT WOULD
BE A LIKE A BLIND MAN CHOOSING
BETWEEN COLORS AND THE DIRECT
REPRESENTATION OF THE DIRECT
DELEGATES AND THEY EVEN
STRUCTURED THE HOUSE, SO IT
WOULD BE INSULATED FROM THE
POPULAR OPINION.  CREATING A
VERY SMALL HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND THE
INDIVIDUAL CONGRESSMAN WOULD BE
WITH CERTAIN CON STITCH WENCIES.
AND BACK AT THE TIME IT WAS
LIKE 40 OR 30,000.  YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT CONSTITUENCY 20
TIMES AS LARGE FOR THE HOUSE AS
IN MASSACHUSETTS LEGISLATURE.
FAIRLY LARGE CONSTITUENCIES IN
FAIRLY GEOGRAPHIC AREAS.  THE
REASON FOR THAT IS TWOFOLD AND
THE PEOPLE MORE AFTER FLEWENT
AND THE LARGER THE CON STITCH
WENCY, THE LARGER THE
REPRESENTATIVE AND THE
CONSTITUENT.  AND 65
CONSTITUENT.  AND 65 FOR THE
ENTIRE COUNTY.  THE NEXT POINT
AMONG THE SAME DIMENSION AND
AUTHORIZING CONGRESS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CONSTITUENCIES
WERE EVEN LARGER.  PROVIDING
THAT CONGRESS CAN CHANGE THE
STATE REGULATIONS FOR THE TIME,
PLACE, AND MANNER OF THE FEDERAL
ELECTIONS.  WHAT THEY HAD IN
MIND WAS THAT CONGRESS COULD SAY
TO A STATE LEGISLATURE, WE
INSIST THAT YOU ELECT YOUR
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVE AT
LARGE, RATHER THAN BY DISTRICT.
VIRGINIA WAS THE LARGEST AND THE
MOST POWERFUL STATE AT THE TIME
OF THE FOUNDING. VIRGINIA HAD
TEN REPRESENTATIVES AND YOU HAVE
TO ASSUME THEY HAD TO BE
DIFFERENT CONSTITUENCIES AND
THE FLAMERS FIGURED THAT
CONGRESS WOULD PICK TEN
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE ENTIRE STATE.  EVERY
VIRGINIAN VOTES FOR EVERY
REPRESENTATIVE AND THAT WOULD BE
EVEN AN ENORMOUS CONSTITUENT
AND THEY WOULD BE EVEN MORE
INSULATED FROM THE DIRECT
SUPERVISION OF THEIR
CONSTITUENTS.  AND THE RECALL
AND THE MANDATORY ROTATION IN
OFFICE.  EACH OF WHICH, I WILL
ELABORATE IN A SECOND AND UNDER
THE ARTICLES OF CONFEDERATION,
THEY EXISTED AND THE FRAMERS
CONSCIOUSLY LEFT THEM OUT OF THE
FEDERAL CONSTITUTION.
INSTRUCTION IS PRETTY MUCH WHAT
IT SOUNDS LIKE AND THE MECHANISM
THAT ALLOWS THE CONSTITUENTS TO
INSTRUCT THEM HOW TO VOTE.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THAT FOR THE
MOST PART BACK THEN.  BUT A NEW
ENGLAND TOWN MEETING COULD SAY
TO ITS REPRESENTATIVE, WE WANT
YOU TO VOTE THIS WAY ON RAISING
TAXES AND IF YOU DIDN'T WHAT
YOUR CONSTITUENTS INSTRUCTED YOU
TO DO, YOU WOULD BE MORALLY
ABOUT  DOCTOR -- ABOUT BRIDGED
TO RECALL YOUR SEAT.  AND AT ANY
POINT IN OFFICE, THEY WOULD BE
RECALLED BY THEIR STATE
LEGISLATURES.  YOU CAN BE SURE
THAT THE STATE LEGISLATURES DID
THEIR BIDDING OR IMMEDIATELY
REMOVED FOR THE OFFICE.  THE
CONSTITUTION DOESN'T PROVIDE FOR
THAT.  UNDER THE ARTICLES, YOU
CAN ONLY SERVE THREE OUT OF
EVERY SIX YEARS AND AFTER
SERVING THE SIX YEARS, YOU ARE
ROTATED OUT OF OFFICE.  AVOIDING
THE
LEGISLATURES FROM GETTING
EMBEDDED IN OFFICE.  THEY WANT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOT TO BE
SUSCEPTIBLE OF THE
POPULOUS IMPULSES AND SHUT DOWN
ANY STATE LEGISLATURE IF A
STATE TRIES TO PASS IT GOING
FORWARD.  THAT'S THE FIRST PART
OF MY TALK.  THE SECOND PART IS
EXPLAINING HOW
THE CONVENTION.  AND THE
ANTI-FEDERALISTS AND THE PEOPLE
WHO OPPOSED RATIFICATION AND THE
DEMOCRATIC AND THE ARISTOCRATIC
PARTS OF THE COMMUNITY WERE
IN  DIFFERENTLY REPRESENTED IN
PHILADELPHIA.  HERE'S SOME
DISCREET POINTS THAT MAY ADD UP
TO AN EXPLANATION AND I'M GOING
TO PUT MY POINTS ON THE COUNTER
REVOLUTION AND I DON'T THINK
THAT ANYBODY HAS SUFFICIENTLY
EXPLAINED WHY THE PHILADELPHIA
CONVENTION WAS SO
UNREPRESENTATIVE AND HOW THEY
CONVINCED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
DEPRIVE THEM OF SIGNIFICANT
INFLUENCE OVER THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT.  THE STATE
LEGISLATURES ELECTED THE
DELEGATES FOR THE PHILADELPHIA
CONVENTION, EXCEPT FOR ONE.
RHODE ISLAND DIDN'T SEND
DELEGATES TO PHILADELPHIA AND
OTHER
STATES, THE STATES CHOSE THE
DELEGATES.  THEY SIMPLY CHOSE
THEIR MOST EMINENT, WELL-KNOWN,
LARGE REPUTATION CITIZENS.  IN
PENNSYLVANIA, THEY ARE GOING TO
SEND BENJAMIN
FRANKLIN AND GEORGE WASHINGTON
AND CHOOSING THE WELL-KNOWN,
EMINENT CITIZENS AND THE WAY
THAT YOU WOULD REQUIRE SUCH A
REPRESENTATION IS EITHER SERVING
FROM THE CONFEDERATION CONGRESS
AND/OR THE REVOLUTIONARY ARMY.
THE MAJORITY OF DELEGATES SERVED
IN THE CONFEDERATION CONGRESS
AND THE REVOLUTIONARY ARMY.  IF
YOU SERVED IN THE CONFEDERATION
CONGRESS, YOU ARE USED TO
THINKING IN PA ROCK KEEL TERMS
AND IN ADDITION MANY PEOPLE WHO
SERVED IN THE REVOLUTIONARY
YEARN LEARNED TO DISTRUST THE
STATE, LIKE GEORGE WASHINGTON
AND JOHN MARSHALL AND SAW THE
STATE OFTEN AS BEING OBSTRUCTIVE
AND REFUSING TO ANTI-UP MAN AND
ANTI-UP MONEY AND TURNED THEM
INTO NATIONALISTS FOR LIFE.
THEY TENDED TO BE WELL
EDUCATED, LARGE LANDOWNERS AND
NOT HAVING A POP PEW
HIS INFLUENCE ON GOVERNMENT.
IT HAD NO REASON TO MOBILIZE AND
ADVANCE THAT AGENDA BECAUSE
THEY HAD NO REASON TO SUSPECT
THAT'S WHAT THE PHILADELPHIA
CONVENTION WOULD BE UP.  ENDS
UP, IT WAS IN THE HEAD OF ONE
MAN, JAMES MADISON.  HE SERVED
IN THE CONFEDERATION CONGRESS
AND VIRGINIA LEGISLATURE AND HE
WAS WELL REGARDED AND PEOPLE
LIKED HIM.
HE WAS NOT A FORMIDABLE SPEAKER
AND OFTEN, THE REPORTER HAD TO
WRITE DOWN WHAT MADISON WAS
TALKING AND HE WAS
SICKLY AND DIDN'T HAVE A BIG
PRESENCE LIKE GEORGE WASHINGTON.
HE PLAYED A LARGE ROLE BECAUSE
HE WAS THE BEST PREPARED MAN IN
THE ROOM.
ALWAYS THE BEST PREPARED PERSON
IN ANY DEBATE.  MADISON SPENT
THE MONTHS BEFORE THE
PHILADELPHIA CONVENTION
SYSTEMATICALLY ANALYZES THE
CONFEDERACY AND DIAGNOSING THE
PROBLEMS THEY TENDED TO SUFFER
FROM AND PROPOSING SOLUTIONS.
HE QUEERED  -- COORDINATED AMONG
HIS VIRGINIA DELEGATES AND THEY
ARRIVED A FEW HOURS EVERY DAY
TALKING THROUGH THEIR NEW IDEAS
FOR THE GOVERNMENT AND TOGETHER,
THESE TWO LARGE STATES, THE
THREE LARGEST STATES AT THE TIME
WERE VIRGINIA, PENNSYLVANIA AND
MASSACHUSETTS.  THEY ARE THERE
EARLY AND THE LARGEST STATES AND
COD NATING ON A FAIRLY
NATIONALIST ANTI-POPULIST AGENDA
AND IT IS CALLED THE VIRGINIA
PLAN AND IT TURNS OUT THAT
PROPOSAL WAS VERY NATIONALIST
AND ANTI-POPULIST.  OBVIOUSLY,
WHERE YOU END UP DEPENDS ON
WHERE YOU START AND THEY STARTED
ON A POPULIST POINT ON THE
SPECTRUM.
TEN DELEGATES DECIDED TO TURN
DOWN THEIR POPULIST.
THEY BECAME LEADING
ANTI-FEDERALISTS AND APPOINTED
TO THE PHILADELPHIA CONVENTION
AND DIDN'T GO AND BECAME LEADING
PROPONENTS OF RATIFICATION.  IT
IS HARD TO KNOW WHY THEY DIDN'T
GO.  SOME OF WHAT THEY SAID AND
IT IS A FAIRLY SMALL SAMPLE
SIZE AND DANGEROUS TO SPECK CUE
LATE AND ONE POSSIBILITY IS THAT
THESE PEOPLE DIDN'T GO BECAUSE
THEY HAD LITTLE SYMPATHY FOR THE
MILDLY CONVENTION AND THEY
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON IN
PHILADELPHIA WAS A FAIRLY
REVOLUTIONARY REFORM PROJECT AND
IF THEY KNEW THAT, THEY MIGHT
HAVE GONE TO FIGHT AGAINST IT.
BUT THEY DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN, SO THEY DIDN'T
GO.  SOME DELEGATES WENT TO THE
PHILADELPHIA CONVENTION AND
DIDN'T APPROVE TO THE
NATIONALIST AND ANTI-POPULIST
DIRECTION AND LEFT EARLY.
LEAVING ONLY ALEXANDER HAMILTON,
WHO WAS THE
LARGEST NATIONALIST AND
ANTI-POPULIST OF THEM ALL.
LUTHER MARTIN WAS ONE THAT LEFT
THE CONVENTION EARLY AND BECAME
ONE OF THE LARGEST
ANTI-NATIONALISTS IN MARYLAND
AND YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
LEFT.  IT WAS DOING SOMETHING I
WILL HEEGITIMATE AND THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO STAY.  YOU CAN STAY AND
FIGHT AGAINST IT AND MAKE IT
LESS OBJECTIONABLE.  THEY CHOSE
TO LEAVE AND THAT WAS PROBABLY A
MISTAKE.  AND
FIFTH, THEY CLOSED THE DOORS TO
THE PHILADELPHIA CONVENTION AND
MADISON SAID IF THEY HADN'T
DONE THIS, THEY MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO COME UP WITH ANY
CONSTITUTION AT ALL.
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR CLOSING
THE DOORS IT LIMITED THE
DELEGATES TO TAKE VERY EXTREME
ANTI-NATIONALIST POSITIONS AND
IF THEY WERE MAKING THESE
STATEMENTS WITH THE PRESS IN THE
GALLERIES AND CLOSING THE
CONVENTION MEANT THAT THE
ANTI-FEDERALISTS, THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE GOING TO OPPOSE THE
CONSTITUTION WERE DEPRIVED OF
FOUR MONTHS OF OPPOSITION.  IF
THE ANTI-FEDERALISTS WOULD HAVE
KNOWN WHAT WAS GOING ON, THEY
COULD HAVE STARTED IMMEDIATELY
ORGANIZING THEIR OPPOSITION, BUT
THEY DIDN'T KNOW UNTIL THE
CONVENTION OPENED ITS DOORS.
AND THE DELEGATES MADE A MOMENT
MOMENTOUS DECISION TO SEIZE THE
CONVENTION AND MADISON IS AIRING
HIS IDEAS AND THINKING THROUGH
HIS IDEAS ABOUT TALKING ABOUT
AND WITH THE LETTERS WITH
WASHINGTON, THEY FIND WITH THEIR
MUTUAL SATISFACTION THEY AGREE
IT IS NOT TEMPORAL EXPEEDENS AND
THEY WANT THE CONSTITUTION TO
DO SOMETHING MORE.  GIVE UH P ON
THE IDEA OF INCREMENTAL REFORM
AND DO SOMETHING MORE DRASTIC.
AND WHEN HE INTRODUCES THE PLAN
AND GEORGE WASHINGTON IS
IMMEDIATELY MADE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CONVENTION AND ACCORDING
TO MADISON'S NOTES.  HE,
RANDOLPH, WOULD NOT AS FAR AS
DEPENDENT ON HIM WOULD NOT LEAVE
ANYTHING NECESSARY UNDONE.  THE
PRESENT MOMENT IS FAVORABLE.
AND PROBABLY THE LAST.  THEY
WENT FOR BROKE AND TO GET THE
TYPE OF GOVERNMENT THEY REALLY
WANTED AND THEY WERE GOING TO
PURSUE SOME MORE
RADICAL REFORM.
THEY TRIMMED THEIR SAILS TO SOME
EXTEND TO ENSURE THE LIKELIHOOD
OF RATIFICATION AND THEY WERE
GOING TO OVERHAUL THE
GOVERNMENT.  HOW DID THEY GET
THIS RATIIED WHEN IT IS SO
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT PEOPLE WERE
EXPECTING AND PROBABLY WANTING.
IT IS A POINT OF EMPHASIS AND
YOU SHOULDN'T ASSUME THIS WAS
INEVITABLE AND IT WAS A HIGHLY
CONTINGENT SERIES OF EVENTS.  IT
ALMOST FAILED.
TWO STATES REJECTED THE
RATIFICATION BEFORE CHANGING ITS
MIND.  AND THE FEDERALISTS, THE
SUPPORTERS OF THE CONSTITUTION
HAD ARRANGED FOR THE CONVENTION
TO BE ADJOURNED WHEN THEY SAW
THEY WERE GOING TO LOSE AND THEY
COULD COME BACK IN A FEW MONTHS
AND FIGHT AGAIN.  IN VIRGINIA,
THE VOTE
WAS 89-79.  AND IN
MASSACHUSETTS IT WAS
187-168 IN FAVOR.  THOSE ARE
THE TWO LARGEST STATES AND IF 1
OR 2 HAD REJECTION THE
CONSTITUTION, IT WAS PROBABLE
THAT THE CONSTITUTION WOULD HAVE
GONE INTO EFFECT.  EVEN IF
NINE STATES RATIFIED, YOU
COULDN'T HAVE DONE IT WITHOUT
VIRGINIA AND MASSACHUSETTS AND
PENNSYLVANIA.  THE THREE LARGEST
STATES.  THIS IS NOT A RIGGED
SYSTEM, NOT A SCAM, BUT IT TURNS
OUT THAT IT WAS NOT AN ENTIRELY
FAIR FIGHT AND AN EVEN PLAYING
FIELD.  THE FEDERALISTS
ADVANTAGE WITH MALL PROPORTION
IN SOME STATES, ESPECIALLY,
SOUTH CAROLINA.  IN SOUTH
CAROLINA AND 20% OF THE WHITE
POPULATION AND ONLY MEN AND
THOSE THAT OWN LAND ARE
VOTING.
AND 20% OF THE POPULATION LIVES
IN COASTAL AREAS ALONG THE
ATLANTIC SEA BOARD AND THE
SUPPORT IS VERY STRONG IN THOSE
AREAS AND IT ELECTS 60% OF THE
DELEGATES AT THE RATIFYING
CONVENTION BECAUSE OF THE
MISPROPORTION.  AND PEOPLE WHO
HAVE POLITICAL POWERS TEND TO BE
ALTRUISTIC IN NOT SHARING IT.
A
MAR -- MAJORITY OF THE
POPULATION OPPOSED THE
CONSTITUTION AND BECAUSE OF
SEVERAL PROPORTION, TWO-THIRDS
OF THE VIRGINIA DELEGATES VOTED
IN FAVOR.  90% OF AMERICANS
LIVED OUTSIDE OF CITIES IN
1877 AND 1878 AND THE
NEWSPAPERS TENDED TO BE
OVERWHELMING SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
ANY FEDERALISTS HAD A HARD TIME
EVEN GETTING THEIR ESSAYS
REPRINTED IN MANY STATES.  AND
THE LEADING FEDERALIST IN SOUTH
CAROLINA COMPLAINED THAT THE
WHOLE WEIGHT AND INFLUENCE OF
THE PRESS WAS ON THE SIDE OF THE
CONSTITUTION.  ONLY 12 OF THE
90 NEWSPAPERS IN CIRCULATION IN
THE ENTIRE COUNTY
POSTED IN FAVOR OF THE
FEDERALISTS.  IT IS LIKE TODAY,
ONLY HAVE FOX NEWS.  FOR
EXAMPLE, IN NEW YORK, 19
OUT OF EVERY 20 VOTERS IS
ANTICIPATING ELECTING DELEGATES
FOR THE CONVENTION, 19 OUT OF 20
VOTED FOR A FEDERALIST DELEGATE
AND THIS HAD AN EFFECT IN WHERE
THE ELECTIONS WERE HELD INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
RATIFYING CONVENTION AND ALL OF
THE ELECTIONS WERE OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC AND THAT MEAN THAT THE
GALLERIES TENDED TO BE DOMINATED
BY SPECTATORS AND THE CITIES
TENDED TO BE DOMINATED BY THE
FEDERALIST SPECTATORS WHO WERE
NOT SHY ABOUT VOICING THEIR
OPINIONS.  IF THE FEDERALISTS
GOT UP TO SPEAK, THEY WOULD BE
BOOED AND HISSED AT.  DIFFICULT
FOR ANY FEDERALIST TO GEFRN --
EVEN GET THEIR OPINION
VOICED.
HOLDING OPEN HOUSES AT THEIR
HOMES DURING THE DURATION OF THE
SOUTH CAROLINA CONVENTION AND
ADJOURN TO THEIR HOMES AFTER THE
DAY'S DELIBERATIONS WERE OVER
AND YOU CAN BE SURE THEY WERE
WHISPERING INTO THE EAR'S OF THE
DELEGATES, THE POSITIVE AND
GLOWING THINGS OF THE
CONSTITUTION.  FEDERALISTS JUST
HAD AN EASIER TIME ORGANIZING
THEIR SUPPORTERS.  THIS IS AN
ERA OF VERY RUDIMENTARY
COMMUNICATION AND THE AREAS THAT
WERE REMOTE FROM THE COMMERCIAL
CONNECTION AND REMOTE FROM THE
ROADS, THEY TENDED TO OPPOSE THE
CONSTITUTION.  IF YOU WOULD
ASSUME THAT THE FEDERALISTS AND
THE ANTI-FEDERALISTS ARE EQUAL
IN NUMBER, THE FEDERALISTS HAD
AN EASIER TIME ORGANIZING THAN
THE ANTI-FEDERALISTS.  AND THE
ELITE OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORTED
RADIFICATION, THAN IN THE STATE
OF VIRGINIA.  THAT WAS A BIG
ADVANTAGE FOR FEDERALISTS
IN THE RATIFYING CONVENTIONS
WHEN THE
ANTI-MATERIAL -- FEDERALISTS
WERE OPEN TO HAVING THEIR MINDS
CHANGED.  ANTI-ELITISM
225 YEARS AGO.  I'M GOING TO
MENTION A COUPLE OF OTHER POINTS
AND THEM I'M GOING TO BE DONE
AND HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THE GENIUS OF THE ARTICLE SEVEN
WAS A HUGE POINT AND PUTTING THE
CONSTITUTION INTO OPERATION AND
NO STATE COULD BIND ANY OTHER.
UNANIMOUS STATE CONSENT AND THE
ARTICLES WERE NEVER SUCCESSFULLY
AMENDED.  THEY COULDN'T BE
BOUND WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT, BUT
ALSO NOT PART OF THE COUNTRY,
UNLESS THEY RATIFIED.  IT IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE
IT IS PRESERVEG EVERY STATE'S
RIGHT TO GO ITS OWN WAY.  ONCE
NINE STATES HAD RATIFIED, THE
OTHER STATES WOULD BE -- THEY
ARE NOT IN THE COUNTRY AND YOU
HAVE A NEW COUNTRY AND THEY ARE
NOT GUARANTEED MILITARY
PROTECTION AND SUBJECT TO
FOREIGN TRADE TAXIFICATION AND
CUT OUT THE IMPORTANT DECISIONS
THAT WERE MADE BY THE FIRST NEW
CONGRESS AND ONCE THE NEW
CONGRESS MET, IT IS GOING TO
HAVE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
DECISIONS TO MAKE.
LIKE WHERE TO PLACE THE NATIONAL
CAPITOL AND THE ADOPTION OF THE
CONSTITUTION.  AND ONCE THE
NINE STATES RATIFIED, THE OTHER
FOUR DIDN'T HAVE A CHOICE AND
THEY JUST MADE IT UP AT THE
PHILADELPHIA CONVENTION AND
ENTERING INTO THE CONVENTION,
EVERYBODY THOUGHT BECAUSE THE
CONVENTION SAID IT, ANYTHING
PROPOSED WOULD HAVE TO BE
APPROVED BY CONGRESS AND THEY
JUST CHANGED THE RULES AND
THOUGHT THEY COULD GET AWAY WITH
IT, AND THEY COULD.
ESPECIALLY, IN NEW YORK AND
VIRGINIA, WHERE ANY
ANTI-FEDERALIST MET, IT WAS NINE
MONTHS AFTER THE PHILADELPHIA
CONVENTION ENDED AND I THINK
THEY CALCULATED IT WAS GOING THE
GIVE THEM MORE TIME TO RALLY
THEIR SUPPORTERS.
WHAT THEY DID, THEY MADE
THEMSELVES IRRELEVANT AND BY THE
TIME IT WAS UNDERWAY IN LATE
JUNE.  NEW HAMPSHIRE WAS THE
NINTH STATE TO RATIFY AND THE
VIRGINIA CONVENTION WAS THE
TENTH STATE TO RATIFY AND IT
HUGELY CHANGED THE CALCULUS IN
NEW YORK.  WHETHER YOU LIKE THE
CONSTITUTION OR NOT, DO YOU WANT
TO BE PART OF THE NEW NATION
AND THE NATION'S CAPITOL IS IN
NEW YORK AND THEY WERE GOING TO
LOSE IT IF THEY DIDN'T JOIN THE
UNION AND THEY WERE GOING TO
LOSE HARD CURRENCY AND HAD
VIRGINIA OR NEW YORK CHOSEN TO
GO IN A DIFFERENT FAVOR, IT
COULD HAVE INFLUENCED THE LATER
STATES.  ONE THING I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE AND THE FEDERALISTS
MANAGED TO DO SOMETHING ELSE AND
I LEARNED THIS WORKING ON THE
BOOK AND IT WAS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO THEIR SUCCESS TO
KEEP THE IMMEDIATE OPTIONS OFF
OF THE TABLE.  AND THE
CONSTITUTION, WHICH AT LEAST,
HALF OF THE COUNTRY WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY FLAWED.  THEY
WANTED TO DENY PEOPLE A CHOICE
ON THE SPECTRUM SOMEWHERE IN THE
MIDDLE BETWEEN THE ARTICLES AND
THE VASTLY MORE NATIONNATIONAL
IST AND POPULIST CONSTITUTION.
THE TWO WAYS TO ARRIVE AT AN
INTERMEDIATE SOLUTION WERE THE
FOLLOWING PROCEDURAL MECHANISMS.
ONE WAS AMEND THE CONSTITUTION
BEFORE IT GETS RATIFIED RATHER
THAN AFTERWARDS AND THEN, LET'S
HOLD
A SECOND CONVENTION.  ANY
FEDERALISTS, THEY MADE GOOD
ARGUMENTS.  WHO IN THEIR RIGHT
MIND -- PATRICK HENRY SAID THIS,
YOU HAVE TO BE A LUNATIC TO
SIGN A CONTRACT WITH ANOTHER
PARTY WHEN THAT PARTY GETS TO
CHANGE THE TERMS THAT YOU HAVE
ALREADY AGREED TO.  THAT'S LIKE
AGREE TOGETHER THE CONSTITUTION
WITH AMENDMENTS TO COME.  YOU
SHOULD INSIST ON SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS IN ADVANCE, WHICH
SEEMS PRETTY REASONABLE.  AND IT
WAS UNVEILED AT A SECRET
CONVENTION AND WE HAVE HAD A BIG
NATIONAL DEBATE AND PEOPLE HAVE
TOLD YOU ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS
AND
NOW, LET'S VOTE FOR MORE
DELEGATES AND GET TO A MORE
INTERMEDIATE POSITION, WHICH IS
WHERE MOST OF THE DELEGATES WERE
AT.  THEY OPPOSED THESE
ALTERNATIVES BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTOOD THAT
A SECOND CONVENTION WOULD ALAW
THEM TO PRESERVE THE CORE OF
WHAT THEY HAD DONE IN
PHILADELPHIA.  THEY WANTED TO
ARRIVE AT WHAT MOST AMERICANS
AGREED WITH, BUT WHAT THEY
THOUGHT WAS BEST FOR THE
NATION'S GOOD.  RANDOLPH, THE
GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA AND MADISON
ARE CORRESPONDING.  AND MADISON
IS TOYING WITH HIS IDEAS AND
RANDOLPH SAYS, WE SHOULD PRESENT
IT TO THE COUNTRY IN A
DISATTACHED FORM AND MADISON
WAS HORRIFIED BY THIS.  THIS IS
WHAT MADISON SAID TO JEFFERSON
LATER THAT YEAR." IN VIRGINIA
WHERE THE MASS OF PEOPLE ARE
ACCUSTOMED TO BE GUIDED BY THEIR
LEADERS, THE MATTER OF WHETHER
TO RATIFY OR NOT RATIFIED
THE CONSTITUTION SURPASSS WHAT
MOST ARE INFORMED
ON ".  TO SUM UP IN ONE MINUTE.
THE CONSTITUTION IS MORE POP
PEW HIS THAT WHAT MANY AMERICANS
WANTED AND THEY BARELY GOT IT
RATIFIED AND BENEFITTING FROM
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT PROVED
ADVANTAGEOUS AND MISCALCULATIONS
BY THEIR POLITICAL ADVERSE SAYS
AND SOME LUCK.  WHETHER YOU
AGREE WITH WHAT THEY DID IN
PHILADELPHIA AND YOU THINK IT IS
LEGITIMATE OR I WILL
LEGITIMATE, YOU HAVE TO STAND
BACK WITH ADMIRATION OF WHAT
THEY ACCOMPLISHED BECAUSE IT WAS
A TYPE OF CO.  THIS IS NOT WHAT
MOST AMERICANS BARGAINED FOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.  I
CAN TAKE SOME QUESTIONS.  I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH TIME WE
HAVE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THING THAT YOU DIDN'T MENTION
IS THE BILL OF RIGHTS, THAT
MUST HAVE PLAYED A BIG PART IN
THE CONVENTION AND THE
RATIFICATION OR DID IT NOT?"
>> THE BILL OF RIGHTS IS TACKLED
IN THE LAST
CHAPTER OF THE BOOK.
NO STATE DELEGATION SUPPORTED
THEM.  THE FEDERALISTS DURING
THE RATIFYING CONVENTION HAD TO
EXPLAIN AND DEFEND THE ABSENCE
OF THE BILL OF RIGHTS AND THAT'S
THE NUMBER ONE OBJECTION THERE
IS NO BILL OF RIGHTS AND THE
PROTECTION OF FREEDOM OF SPEECH
AND FREEDOM OF THE PRESS AND SO
ON.  THE FEDERALISTS HAD
ARGUMENTS WHY THEY THOUGHT THE
EXISTENCE OF THE BILL OF RIGHTS
WOULD BE DANGEROUS.  IT IS NOT
CLEAR TO ME IF THEY WOULD HAVE
OPPOSED THE BILL OF RIGHTS IF IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN PROPOSED IN THE
CONVENTION AND THEY WERE THERE
FOR TEN LONG HOT SUMMER MONTHS
AND THE DELEGATES JUST SAID THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO DEAL WITH THIS.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE A PRINCIPLE
MISTAKE AND MADISON WAS RUNNING
FOR OFFICE AND WANTED TO BE
ELECTED TO THE FIRST CONGRESS
FROM VIRGINIA AND IT INCLUDED A
LARGE SHARE OF THE CENTRAL
VIRGINIA BAPTISTS AND THEY HAD
BEEN OPPRESSED AND MANY BAPTIST
PREACHERS HAD BEEN THROWN IN
JAIL FROM THE PREVIOUS DECADE.
THEY COULDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THERE WAS NO PROTECTION FOR
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY IN THE
CONSTITUTION.  AND MADISON WAS
RUNNING AGAINST JAMES MONROE, A
REVOLUTIONARY WAR HERO AND THIS
WAS A DISTRICT THAT HAD BEEN
GERRYMANDERED TO KEEP PATRICK
HENRY OUT OF THE FIRST CONGRESS
AND NOW, HE WOULD SUPPORT A
BILL OF RIGHTS NOW THAT THE
CONSTITUTION HAD BEEN RATIFIED
AND MADISON GETS UP IN CONGRESS
ON JUNE 8, 1879, AND SAYS I'M
PROPOSING THE AMENDMENTS TO THE
CONGRESS.  THEY ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN WHAT MADISON IS
PROPOSING.  THEY WANT STRUCTURAL
CHANGES AND LIMIT THE TAXING
POWERS AND THE MILITARY POWERS.
THAT'S WHAT MADISON OFFERS, THE
RIGHT AGAINST SEARCH AND SEIZURE
AND ROBUST, SIGNIFICANT
PROTECTIONS.  THEY WANT LIMITS
ON NATIONAL POWER RATHER THAN
THE RIGHTS PROTECTIONS AND THE
CONGRESS SAID TO MADISON, NOW
THAT YOU HAVE DONE YOUR DUTY,
YOU NEED TO SIT DOWN AND BE
QUIET BECAUSE WE HAVE IMPORTANT
THINGS TO DO LIKE RAISING THE
TAXES AND WHY SHOULD
WE BE AMENDING THE CONSTITUTION
AND MADISON PERSISTS AND MAKES
ARGUMENTS AND IF WE DON'T
DELIVER WHAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS WERE PROMISED,
THEY ARE NEVER GOING TO TRUST US
AND MADISON PERSISTS AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY, HE'S ABLE TO
GET CONGRESS TO APPROVE THE TEN
AMENDMENTS AND THAT'S HOW WE GET
THE BILL OF RIGHTS.  IT IS
FASCINATING AND NEITHER SIDE
CARES MUCH ABOUT THE RIGHTS
PROVISIONS AND THEY THINK OF
THEM AS PARCHMENT
BARRIERS.  AND'S NOT WHAT WE
THINK TODAY BECAUSE WE CELEBRATE
OUR BILL OF RIGHTS AND THE
JUDGES ENFORCE THEM, BUT IN
1879, NEITHER SIDE THINKS IT IS
IMPORTANT IN THE CONSTITUTION.
THE ADOPTION OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND MOST OF THE
ANTI-FEDERALISTS HAD COME
AROUND AND JAMES MADISON WAS
MORE OR LESS THE MAJORITY LEADER
AND I WONDER IF JAMES MADISON
WOULD HAVE SEEN THIS AS A
SUCCESSFUL COO AND IF THE
ANTI-FEDERALISTS WOULD HAVE ALSO
RETHOUGHT THE SITUATION?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION. I
HAVE TO BREAK IT INTO TWO PARTS
AND THE FIRST PART, WHAT
HAPPENED TO
THE CRITICAL
CRITICISM.  AND JAMES WOOD, ONE
OF THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
POLITICAL WRITER IN THIS PERIOD,
AND THE ANTI-FEDERALISTS DID
GIVE UP THEIR ANTI-HE
GET --
ANTI-LEGITIMACY DEBATE AND THIS
IS I WILL
GET
ATE.
ATE.  PEOPLE WHO ARE MORE
DUBIOUS MIGHT HAVE SAID IT IS
ABOUT GREAT BRITAIN OPENED UP A
DEMAND FOR AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS
AND THE UNITED STATES WAS MORE
INTERESTED IN THE LAW AND WITH
THE BOOMING ECONOMY, PEOPLE ARE
NOT AS INTERESTED IN OBJECTING
TO THE ARRANGEMENTS THAT
EXIST.  THE CONSTITUTION QUICKLY
PROVES THAT THE
ANTI-FEDERALISTS TYPES COULD
MAKE THE SAME ARGUMENTS THEY
MADE AGAINST THE CONSTITUTION
WITHIN THE CONSTITUTION.  ONE OF
THE FIRST DEBATES IS IF
CONGRESS CAN CHARTER A NATIONAL
BANK.
AND JAMES MADISON SAYS THERE IS
NOTHING IN THE POWER THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO CHARTER A BANK.  AND
ALEXANDER HAMILTON SAID ON THE
OTHER HAND, IF CONGRESS CAN
RAISE TAXES, WOULDN'T IT BE
CONVENIENT TO HAVE A BANK.  THE
ARGUMENTS OF WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION MEANS AND IF THE
STATE SENATE THAT APPROVED THE
SECRETARY OF STATE PLAYS A ROLE
IN REMOVING THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.  JAMES MADISON ATTACKS IT
AND SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT
CAN ONLY DECLARE WAR AND NOT
PEACE.  AND IT TURNS OUT THAT
THE ANTI-FEDERALISTS TYPE CAN GO
ON MAKING THEIR SAME STATE
RIGHTS POPULIST
ARGUMENTS UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION AND IN THE FIRST
CIVIL WAR, THEY
DOMINATE THE GOVERNMENT.
WHAT'S THE POINT OF ATTACKING
THE CONSTITUTION WHEN YOU CAN
CONTROL ITS INTERPRETATION.  AND
MADISON SEEMED LIKE A
HUGE NATIONALIST IN
1787.  BY 798, MADISON IS
ARGUING TO NULL FIE A FEDERAL
LAW AND HE'S WRITING RESOLUTIONS
FOR THE VIRGINIA LEGISLATURE
AND THAT A STATE
AUDIT COULD RATIFY THE FEDERAL
LAW.  WHAT HAPPENED TO JAMES
MADISON?  MADISON WAS ONLY A
NATIONALIST WHEN HE HAD IN MIND
THE STATE DEBT RELIEF AND IF THE
STATES ARE GOING TO BE
DISTRIBUTING THE WEALTH FROM THE
DEBTORS, THE STATES NEED TO
SIGN ON TO THAT.  MADISON
DOESN'T THINK THERE SHOULD BE A
NATIONAL BANK AND THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD SUBSIDIZE THE
STATE DEBT AND MADISON IS A
VIRGINIA ARISTOCRAT AND THE
SOUTH VIRTUALLY DOESN'T HAVE ANY
BANKS AND NOW, TRYING TO CREATE